hello and welcome on this week's show
one of the leading voices in America's
Civil Rights Movement Reverend Al
Sharpton this is Beth Rigby interviews
[Music]
George Freud's story has been the story
of black folks the reason we could never
be who we wanted and dream to be in as
you kept your knee on our neck what
happened to Floyd happens every day in
this country
shaving is in the courtroom but America
is on trial Donald Trump and I've known
his other 25 years I've marched on him
with Central Park five he had can say
what he wants he called me a
troublemaker yes I make trouble for
bigots
represents a reckless disregard for our
lives Michael Brown
18 year old boy when I saw Michael
Landry thought about how many of us
[Music]
were just considered nothing
you might have killed the dreamer but
you can't kill the dream
[Music]
the recent killing of Tyree Nichols a
young black man who was beaten by the
police has left America soul-searching
once more
at his funeral tyree's mother said
Congress would have blood on its hands
if it failed to pass a bill limiting
police officer immunity
it should be no other child that should
suffered the way my son and all the
other parents here
have lost their children
we need to get that bill passed while
Reverend Al Sharpton used his eulogy to
question how five black police officers
could be behind the beating of a young
black man in their own community in the
city that Dr King lost his life
not far away from that balcony you beat
a brother to death
there's nothing more insulting
I caught up with Reverend Al Sharpton
during a visit to London this week we
discussed the killing of Tyree Nichols
and why he feels there's been a lack of
progress made in tackling police
brutality since the murder of George
Floyd
Reverend thank you so much for coming on
the show today let's start with this
you've been an American Civil Rights
activist for decades you've delivered
the eulogy at Tyree Nicole's funeral a
young man who died after he was beaten
by five police officers it came not
three years after you delivered the
eulogy at the funeral of George Floyd
how do you find the words to comfort
these families
when you see history repeating itself in
this way
I've been in this struggle around civil
rights and police reform for decades you
know I started when I was 12 years old
as youth director in New York uh for Dr
King's organization uh the year Dr King
was killed so it's part of my life and
when I look at George Floyd almost three
years ago and the fact that in those
three years we were not able to get a
federal law but we did get a executive
order President Biden did sign an
executive order that contained a lot of
what was in the George Floyd Bill and uh
we never had that before I did not think
that uh with George Floyd happening that
police brutality was going to uh stop
happening but I did think we'd be able
to get federal law
and I still think we will but we did get
an executive order I promised a Ford
family among others
George's name is not just going to be a
hashtag your daddy's name is going to be
known for a long time
I think that the thing that was
troubling to me uh Beth about the
killing
uh of uh this young man is that
Tyree was Beat to Death by five black
policemen
minutes away from where Martin Luther
King was killed and Martin Luther King
was in Memphis
fighting for black city workers
I could argue the case they may not have
even been on any Elite Squad if hadn't
been for Dr King so we're fighting
systems as well as race because I don't
believe those black cops would have beat
a white kid like that because they knew
the penalty so I think that we've got to
keep fighting it's not an overnight
fight so many questions for me from from
that answer but but one is the point
that you make that tiray died in Memphis
the same city where Martin Luther King
was assassinated in 1968. is there a
sense of betrayal within the black
community considering the sacrifice
Martin Luther King and all of those who
fought for civil rights like you have
made you are really angry about that
there's something cruel about it isn't
that there's something cool there's
something uh uh of a real betrayal of
what sponsored the possibility for you
to have the job you had and to abuse
that job for whatever reason
there is no reason that to me would
justify beating an unarmed man to death
for to add insult into injury uh for it
to happen in Memphis
it prompted demonstrations across the
country this was Times Square in New
York where several arrests were made
this was the seat on the west coast
where crowds took to the streets of Los
Angeles following the video's release
Memphis the city where Tyree Nichols
lived and died demonstrations extended
into the weekend we want this city to be
a safe place for our children because as
a mother and as a nurse I'm worn the
loss of
um
a kind soul I'm a mother of five black
sons one deceased and it could have been
very well my son whatever the causes are
we need to try to resolve them and not
have this constantly be the end result
you didn't get on the police department
by yourself
didn't get there by herself
people had to March and go to jail and
some lost their lives to open the doors
for you and how dare you
[Applause]
act like that sacrifice was enough for
nothing
you ain't in no New England State you in
Tennessee
where we had to fight for you
reference
it was black police officers
that carried out this attack now when
you heard the reports
of what had happened coming in did you
like many people assume that these would
be white police officer attacking when I
got the call uh from some of the people
in National Action Network in Memphis I
assumed it was way and then when Ben
crumped the uh attorney called me and
said we would like you to come in and
and do the funeral and and help with the
protest but National Action Network he
said but I need to tell you Reverend
these are five black cops
I said all five he said yeah I said then
that's more reason for me to come one we
don't fight against white police
brutality we fight against police
brutality but second how could black
cops do this in the town Dr King was
killed in and Ben said I didn't even
think about the Dr King I said don't
worry I'll be there a day early because
this is repulsive to me and then I
talked to the parents who repeated the
request for me to come and they did my
uh television show and I think that uh
the fact that these black cops
felt they could do this on one side of
town and don't do it on the white side
of town as I said before Beth I don't
think they would have done this to a
white kid someone asked me in Memphis an
interview so well you have to understand
crime is high in the black community how
do they bring Crime down without being
more aggressive I said the same way they
keep crying down in the white Community
without being aggressive are you saying
blacks are inherently more criminal are
you saying you have a disproportionate
criminal uh justice system that
exercises different methods in this case
what made it even more egregious is we
still don't even know what crime they
were trying to arrest him for the police
chief says the videotape says he was not
driving reckless so what were they after
him for and to beat him to death
undoubtedly what they did was
Beyond imagine it's absolutely horrific
what
what do you think is going on are black
police officers susceptible to being
racist is there a broader question of
police brutality what how do you explain
it I think that there is the broader
question of released being not policed
and I think that white and black police
have been uh infested and uh with the
same kind of uh Power trips that I don't
have to be held accountable which is why
the George Floyd Justice and policing
act that we're pushing for uh and have
been pushing for since George Floyd that
as I said Biden did give some in the
executive order but not couldn't make it
federal law because the Senate wouldn't
vote it uh I think that that makes them
accountable why does that make them
accountable because it removes qualified
immunity what they have in the United
States for police it's qualified
immunity where you can't to them
personally
the city or the state pays the damages
if there are someone abused if a
policeman knows he can lose his property
his house his car for his actions his
family would say wait a minute you've
got to be more careful and follow the
letter of the law there's no skin in the
game but reference what you'll say so
you think that these black police
officers thought it that they it was
okay or they could get away with beating
a young black man but they couldn't do
it to a young white man oh absolutely I
feel that they knew it would be an
outrage and they would be held
accountable if they did it to a young
white man I think they felt that this
black guy uh was just another black guy
and who cares they probably didn't think
he was going to die he died three days
later it makes me when I looked at the
videos and heard them saying one thing
and we're looking at another like at one
point they're saying give us your hands
when they were holding up his arms they
had his hands
so it was almost like they were doing a
narrative uh that they were doing for
the body cameras that was not what was
actually happening what really convicts
them is the aerial shots that they
forgot was there so you could see from
the aerial shots everything but you got
to ask yourself the question of why
would they do this at all unless they've
been doing it before and knew how to do
it and try to give a different narrative
the way they behaved it makes me wonder
whether or not this is the first time
they abuse someone
some officers are now worried about the
impact of tyree's death and and what it
has on the image of of black police
officers more generally on efforts to
build more diverse Police Department
Reverend what's your view on that does
that worry you as well no it bothers me
is the whole all police accountable and
I think the question of diversity is a
legitimate question but you can't
diversify brutality you must bring in
police that are trained and sensitive to
the community not just check a box and
say we brought in more black or more
Brown policemen I am a citizen of this
community we share I am a mother I am a
caring human being who wants the best
for all of us this is not just a
professional failing this is a failing
of basic Humanity toward another
individual
this incident was heinous Reckless and
inhumane because it's complicated isn't
it because the Memphis police chief CJ
Davis who's the first African-American
police chief in Memphis was applauded
for her Swift action in firing the
officers responsible for the death of
tiray but she also headed and created
the Scorpion unit which discriminated
against African-Americans
disproportionately and used brutal
methods
I think she deserves credit for uh
arrest or for charging the police uh
well not charging she she deserves
credit for
firing the police before they were
charged she deserves credit but the unit
itself New York Times front page did a
story on the unit itself targeted black
men which goes to my point of can black
uh police officers discriminate that was
their target
and that in itself is wrong you cannot
in the name of I am now a diverse I'm
the first black on an Elite Squad or
whatever position but I'm going to
Target black people you can't have it
both ways
given that you've campaigned for this
all your life do you find it
discombobulate and confusing
when it is black police officers
attacking a black man I I find it or or
an obligation of my part to stand up and
correct it I mean there's always been
blacks used against other blacks we've
got to be just as vocal when it's that
case as it is with whites just like oh
uh Ben Crump and I went to BB Arkansas a
stronghold of Donald Trump and I did the
eulogy for a white kid killed by cops
because it's not always as clear as
black and white is right and wrong but
even when it is black on black we must
be just as vocal
this is the Third Precinct Police
Station in Minneapolis in Flames a
blazing symbol of an anger that isn't
going away this had been a focus of the
protests in this city for days a place
that's become the latest emblem of an
age-old problem in America
the National Guard is on the way and
police once again confronting a
community that feels it's been betrayed
[Applause]
the protests in the face of appeals for
Park like that
[Applause]
is
once again the protests are now playing
out across the country from New York in
the east
to Los Angeles in the west they're angry
at a familiar problem in American
society and they're impatient for
answers
and I
honorable vice president Harris talked
about passing the George Floyd Justice
in policing act as Vice President of the
United States we demand that Congress
passed the George Floyd Justice and
policing act Joe Biden will sign it
and we should not delay and we will not
be denied it is non-negotiable
bill would see a federal ban on the use
of chokeholds by police make it easy to
bring charges the Democrats passed the
bill in the House of Representatives is
stored in the Senate
what are the prospects of passing this
bill now because the Republic the lead
Republican negotiator doesn't seem
minded to to move on this I think that
the uh pressure now is on getting a few
of the Republicans uh and uh the two
Democrats that would not vote the
filibuster last time to vote and I think
there's significant pressure and uh uh
we are in negotiations right now with
members of the Senate through Senate uh
minority a majority leader Chuck Schumer
and we're going to push forward
within hours of arriving in Britain the
Reverend Al Sharpton was in his element
at the head of an anti-racist rally this
time we win next time
the March passed through Thames Mead
scene of a brutal murder last month of a
black 15-year-old youth Roland Adams
the man who's been voted as the most
unpopular American by New Yorkers both
black and white alarmed some britons
after reports last week that he
threatened to make white people's worst
fears come true today he made full use
of his famous rhetoric as he condemned
those who campaigned to keep him out of
Britain if you want to ban somebody Ben
is racists that are trying to kill black
people in this community you've spoken
extensively about racism and the culture
of policing in the U.S you've also
spoken about the situation in the UK you
said the failure to address systemic
racism in UK policing and the culture of
policing that produces brutality against
our people will only lead to more
instances like the tragedy of Tyro
Nichols many many people watching this
might think that the levels of police
violence in the U.S are far different to
that in the UK that these are perhaps
false comparisons what would you say to
people that might think that's a I would
say that you cannot say that when you
have a 24 increase in the UK of uh
blacks being subject to stop and search
after covet uh when you see during
covert that they were pulled over more
uh just because you don't have someone
with a knee on the neck does not mean
discrimination is not discrimination and
profiling is not profiling how do you
explain the disproportionate amount of
citizens that are black are people of
color being stopped and searched to
whites in this uh country how do you
explain in covert when everybody's
locked down people of color and blacks
in particular are stopped and and dealt
with and arrested more than whites there
is a systemic problem and I think the
studies the data has shown that and I
think that is why it is critical that we
get ahead of it and deal with it before
you end up with a George Floyd what do
you think that we should do then not
have stop and search or just stop and
search it is inherently uh set up in a
situation that uh we found when they
called it in America stop and frisk that
it was disproportionately done in areas
where blacks and Browns was when you
have a disproportionate police strategy
you must eliminate that strategy and and
so final question you've been a leading
civil rights activist for decades your
story has been told now through a
documentary which is screening here in
London it's called loudmouth
we are intelligent enough
not to let you tell us
what tactics that you are comfortable
with
to hold us enslaved
you don't have none of us under control
and you will never have us under control
again
that was our beach
it felt like a victory but you knew that
you won a case not changed the system
I've been in the movement since 12 and I
knew the difference between
moments
and movements that won did you pick that
title no uh John Legend the uh the
Entertainer the executive producer and
they uh have a a director who happens to
be a young white uh uh documentarian
very good guy who said that uh he wanted
to do the documentary John Legend and
kadam massenburg or music mogul wanted
to put it out they said I could have no
editorial control and they wanted to
call it loud mouth I said
well you got to understand unlike my uh
uh Heroes Martin Luther King was from
Atlanta Georgia Reverend Jesse Jackson
Who mentored me was from South Carolina
I'm from New York you had to compete
with Broadway lights and radio City and
Empire State Building I mean the city
that never slept you had to be loud to
make your issues heard in New York okay
you couldn't put out a press release and
have a rally at the church and then
moved New York you had to do things that
would grab the attention of the public
and hold it because if you don't have
the attention of the public you will
never change public policy so you are
both the preacher and a performer in
some ways you had to be in New York or
preacher and a performer and then I made
it national and uh you know people that
do things wrong want to keep you quiet I
often say I said it when I was uh
preaching George Floyd's funeral during
the eulogy that people don't call me to
keep a secret they called me because
they want me to bring the attention to
it and sometimes you have to be loud to
bring the attention and keep it there
the president talks about bringing in
the military
but he's not said one word
about eight minutes and 46 seconds of
police murder of George Floyd oh he said
the family has my sympathy and all it is
he didn't give those on other situations
as sympathy he challenged China on human
rights
well what about the human right of
George Floyd
I want to ask you one more thing Mr
Nichols his mother
is coping with her son's loss by hoping
that his death will lead to change and
this is again what we talked about less
than three years ago
with the family of George Floyd and
those global protests do you sir think
that there will genuinely be changed
that this that Tyrese death could be an
inflection point now or do you think
we're going to keep going through this
cycle I believe that tyree's death can
be that I believe the same with George
Floyd where we did get the executive
order I always have hope no matter how
bad it looks you must remember when the
uh historic March on Washington happened
in 1963 with Martin Luther King made the
speech I Have a Dream
two months later they bombed the church
in Birmingham Alabama 16th Street
Baptist Church and killed four little
girls there's always going to be a
reason to give up but you have to keep
going suppose if Mandela had given up 27
years in jail for South Africa ended up
being a democratic one-man one vote
supposedly Dr Kingdom had given up we
would have never had a Barack Obama or
Kamala Harris
so every time I get discouraged I think
of people that face greater odds than we
have and see if they could hold on we
can hold on Victory is certain I don't
know the date of the time but I know we
will win and I won't stop fighting in
your lifetime in my lifetime hopefully
but if not my children will say in their
lifetime or my grandchildren their
lifetime that we won and my dad or my
granddad was part of the victory they
don't they will not say he quit and gave
up Reverend thank you so much for your
time thank you very grateful for it
thank you thank you
reverent our Sharpton known lots to
think about from that conversation now
if you scan this QR code on screen now
you can watch all of our interviews
online and all the previous episodes of
the show and if you scan the QR code on
your screen now you can listen to the
Beth Rigby interviews podcast each week
I take a look at the highlights of the
interviews and there's always a bit of
extra in there on politics of course too
that's on the Sky News app or wherever
you get your podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you to my special guest Reverend Al
Sharpton and thank you for watching
[Music]